سنبدا من شركه
ابك جيمز المنتجه للعبه فورتنايت التي
اثارت جذرا كبيرا بعد اعلانها قبول
التسويه ماليه ستدفع بموجبها غرامه قياسيه
تبلغ
275 مليون دولار لانتهاكها قانون يتعلق
بخصوصيه الاطفال
وستتمنى اعدادات افتراضيه صارمه لحمايه
خصوصيه الاطفال
تحاديه الامريكيه قالت ان الشركه ستدفع
ايضا 200
و45 مليون دولار لرد اموال لمستهلكين
خدعتهم بما يعرف باسم الانماط المظلمه
لاجراء عمليه اجراء لم ينمو القيام بها
تسهل عمليه الشراء وتضلل المستخدمين
للقيام بها دون وعين حقيقي بالعمليه نفسها
من التعليقات في هذا الشان في هذا الموضوع
نقرا لكم سلمى التي قالت فعلا حمايه
البيانات اصبحت مشكله كبيره نعاني فيها مع
اطفالنا ويجب فعلا وضعوا رقابه على هذه
الالعاب
قالت كل مواقع التواصل تقوم بسرقه
البيانات لماذا يتم التركيزه على شركه
معينه دون الاخرى
ايضا احمد المناصره قال سنوات ثلاث سنوات
وانا العب فورت نايت وكل مره اقول انني
ساوقفها حتى اصبحت ادمانا واصرف كل فلوسي
عليها
فورتنايت وغيرها من الالعاب لا تقوم فقط
بجمع البيانات بل تبيعها في ما بعد بعد ان
تقل ارادتها وهذا امر خطير
طبعا هناك مخاطر التقنيه لكن ما يهمنا هنا
في هذه المخاطر هو الادمان على هذه اللعبه
وغيرها من الالعاب ما الذي تفعله هذه الى
الالعاب لكي تجعل ليس فقط الاطفال في
الواقع الاطفال والبالغين مدمنين عليها
انا لست من المدمنين الحمد لله
يعني انا انا من المدمنين عليها اذا نعتبر
هذا المصطلح الالعاب هاي انا من طفولتي
كنت العب على الكمبيوترات اللي فور اي تي
6 والاشياء هاي لكن خلينا نصنف الادمان
هون لدرجات يعني الادمان اذا كان مقصود
فيه انه
الشخص يلعب على اللعبه في وقت فراغه بعد
ان ينتهي من واجباته ومسؤولياته فهذا يعني
شيء تقضي الى وقت اذا كانت اللعبه ممتعه
ومفيده وفيها استراتيجيات فلا باس اما اذا
بنحكي عنه احنا بقضيه اليوم هي المحكمه
وكيف سياسات الخداع اللي بتمارسها الشركات
تبعتها فهنا بصير في عندنا تعود نابع من
شغلتين تعود لانه انت بدك تصير تتفوق على
زملائك في اللعبه عشان تاخذ هرمون
الدوبامين هرمون الانتشاء او السعاده الذي
ياتي من ممارسه الشيء وتقدم فيه والحصول
على نتائج سريعه ومن هون بتجيء اهميه
الشراء داخل اللعبه اللي اصلا سبب المشكله
اللي بالقضيه السياسات الطبليه اللي
بيستخدموها حتى الشخص يصير صور او يتقدم
في مراحل عن زملاؤه طريقه تعرض فيها انه
انت ممكن تشتري 10 خطوات للامام مقابل شخص
بده يحصل عليهم بوقت بده يوم او يومين
فانت بتسابق مع الاخرين فبيصير فيها هذه
الشعور بالتنافس بالنقود وهو اللي بيجي
دور الاستغلال الاطفال
هذا افساد ايضا للاخلاق لانه يجعل التقدم
والنجاح ليس بالجهد
وانما بالمال يشتري بالمال نعم صحيح سيدي
صحيح في كثير من الالعاب لما تقراه
الديسكربشن على الالعاب على التليفونات او
على هاي همم
ليس لها نقود حتى تتفوق فيها الاخرين مما
يجعلها عادي لا اكثر بس للاسف لعبتنا نحكي
عنها اليوم فورتنايت لا يمكن فيها شراء
مراحل وشراء همم اجهزه والعاب كوينز وفي
باكس بيسموها لهم همم بيلعبوا فيها
وبشتروا فيها بتسابقوا فيها على الاخرين
فهذا بخلي كمان في عندنا زي نظام الادمان
بالانجليزي
ومن معه مصاري اكثر وهو بيكون الذي يفوز
فيها يحصل على جوائز اكثر هذا اللي دخل
عندهم ادمان وبس بيفكروا ثاني يوم كيف
يحصلوا على مزيد من التقدم لانه اريد ان
اقول كل ولكن معظم او غالبيه هذه الالعاب
الالكترونيه
لا تبني قيام
السؤال الان كم من المدمنين ولكن نقول من
النوع الاول او النوع الاقل او الاخف همم
وانت كاستشاري نفسي كيف نصيطر على
سلوكنا في استخدام هذه الالعاب دون ان نقع
في مراحل الادمان بمختلف في مراحلها
لازم نحنا نعرف في القيمه اللي بتقدمها
اللعبه انا كنت مدمن مش على هذه الالعاب
الالعاب الاستراتيجيه اللي فيها نمط من
التفكير اللي فيها كيف انت تتفوق بذكائك
وليس بالنقودك زائد كنت انا انظم وقتي
يعني انا الحمد لله درست الطب ودرست
الجامعه وخلصت وما اثرت عليها الالعاب
شيئا في حياتي لانه كان اساس اللعب فيها
عشان اولادنا يلعبوا هالالعاب تحت الاشراف
في الرقابه انا عارف نوع اللعبه وهي
مناسبه لعمرهم ولا لا وما الفائده التي
تقدمها لهم زائد تحديد الوقت لللعب في ما
تكون للحس ساعات مفتوحه جدا حتى لا يحصل
الادمان همم بدنا كمان احنا نجلس معهم
احيانا كابابا وامهات نعرف شو بيلعبوا
الاطفال همم لا تكفي برامج الرقابه او
برامج انه احنا نتبع الطفل شو بسوي هاي لا
تكفي انه تمنع حصول مشاكل من هذا النوع
تحديد الوقت تنظيم الوقت الاشراف والرقابه
بشكل مباشر تكون معهم عادي لو كل الاب
وابن وام جلسوا مع بعد ربع ساعه نصف ساعه
شايف وشل اللعبه اللي يلعبها وناقشوه فيها
وانه شو فائدتها ولا لا حتى يفضل قبل
شراءها ان اشوف السن كل العاب ما بيعرفوا
من الاهالي بكون عليها مكتوب عليها عمر
معين 16 بلس 18 بلس بيكون هاي اللعبه
مناسبه لهذه الفئه العمريه لانه كل شخصيه
بعمار مختلفه يتم التاثير عليها بشكل
مختلف يعني العاب العنف على الاطفال اقل
من 13 سنه تترك بصمه فيهم اثر لما يكون
اللاعب اللي بيلعبها 18 سنه فوق تختلف
القصه نوعا ما انه عارف هذا الشيء بيكون
عالم خيالي وتخيلي وليس حقيقي فننتبه احنا
نقاط هل يعني ليست هذه الالعاب فقط
اللي هو اشكال يعني مثلا ادمان المسلسل
وهذا يقع في الكبار والصغار كيف يمكن
التغلب عليه يعني قولي للاطفال يمكن ان
نجعل لهم في المكان العام في البيت المكان
مشترك وليس في غرف نوم همم لكن ستكون هناك
رقابه طبعا لكن ادمان المسلسل للكبار مثلا
كيف يمكن التخلص منه ان تخلصت منه الحمد
لله يعني خلينا نتفق احنا على مفهوم كلمه
الادمان حتى ال ال لا يفهمون المشاهدين
ادمان هو حاله بيكون الشخص فيها همم مش
قادر يترك الشيء اللي بين ايديه ويفضل عمل
هذا النشاط نحكي مسلسلات على اي نشاط
اجتماعي اخر وتصبح حياته متوام محور حول
هذا الموضوع وعندما يتركه عندما يتوقف عن
عمله بشعر بالانزعاج وبصير معه وارى وقله
النوم ومشاكل الاخرى فكيف يحصل هذا الشيء
يحصل تدريجيا يحصل نتيجه انه اخطائنا في
اداره وقتنا في معرفه همم
اولوياتنا في عدم اعطاء الشيء حقه يعني
احنا كلمه انه ماذا تعني كلمه كفايه او ما
هو المناسب لكلمه كفى نتفرج على مسلسلات
في شيء بيسموه بينجو اللي بيتفرجوا فيها
شباب الان على 10 و20 حلقه متواصل وراء
بعضهم البعض من المسلسلات حتى يخلصوهم
وراء بعضهم البعض هذا من اهم الاسباب اللي
بتخلي عندنا تعلق وبم الجسم مضره للنوم
ومدرر حتى للعقل وذاكرته شكرا شكرا